CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS, SHOULD
THE PRESIDENT'S CORE SUPPORTERS
PANIC?
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
AS I NOTED LAST NIGHT IT WAS
TERRIFIC FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
LET THE SUNLIGHT IN DURING THAT
BACK AND FORTH AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN ASKING FOR
ABOUT HAVING BOTH SIDES OF THE
TABLE, IT WAS REALLY GOOD.
HE ALSO REITERATED THAT THE WALL
AND ENDING CHAIN MIGRATION WAS A
PREREQUISITE FOR ANY DEAL ON THE
SO-CALLED DREAMERS.
COMING.
THEY'RE GOING TO BEAT THE OUT OF
US BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE
AMNESTY ALL OVER AGAIN.
>> Laura: THEN THE PRESIDENT
SECOND THAT EMOTION.
>> President Trump: IT'S VERY
INTERESTING BECAUSE I DO HAVE
PEOPLE -- TO USE THE COMMON
WHAT WE'RE DOING BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE THEY HAVE TO BE.
>> Laura: EXCUSE ME?
LINDSEY GRAHAM HITTING FOX NEWS?
THAT'S NOTHING NEW.
IF THE PRESIDENT HITTING A FAR
RIGHT, THAT'S ADOPTING THE
LANGUAGE OF HIS FIERCEST CRITICS
>> President Trump: HOPEFULLY
THEY COME BACK WITH AN AGREEMENT
I'M SIGNING IT -- I WILL BE
SIGNING IT.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY OH, GEE, I
WANT THIS, I WANT THAT, I WILL
MADE JEB BUSH ALL WARM AND FUZZY
MADE JEB BUSH ALL WARM AND FUZZ
FUZZY.
LOVE AND WE CAN DO THAT.
>> Laura: DOES THAT SOUND A
LITTLE BIT FAMILIAR?
>> YES, THEY BROKE THE LAW BUT
IT'S NOT A FELONY.
CANDIDATE TRUMP RIDICULED LOW
ENERGY JEB FOR THAT?
TELL THAT TO THE FAMILIES AND
THERE ARE MANY, MANY, MANY
>> Laura: REMEMBER CANDIDATE
TRUMP SAYING THIS?
>> NOTE CITIZENSHIP.
>> President Trump: NO
CITIZENSHIP.
LET ME GO A STEP FURTHER.
THEY WILL PAY BACK TAXES, THEY
WHAT HAPPENED?
MAY BE THE PRESIDENT REALIZED
HE'S NEVER GOING TO GET A WALL
UNLESS HE DOES AND DACA AMNESTY.
MAYBE HE THINKS HE JUST CAN'T
AND CHAIN MIGRATION UNLESS HE
GIVES LEGAL STATUS TO THOSE
800,000 ILLEGALS, THEY RANGE
FROM ABOUT 16 TO 30, THEY ARE
NOT ALL KIDS NOW.
THAT IS A HARD PILL FOR MANY OF
HIS MOST LOYAL SUPPORTERS TO
SWALLOW.
TODAY, MANY OF MY RADIO
LISTENERS WERE IN MELTDOWN MODE.
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET A NEW
HE GRANTS AMNESTY TO HIS
>> MY KIDS WERE BORN AND RAISED
IN AMERICA, WE HAVE DREAMS TOO.
IF WE DON'T OBEY THE LAW, NOBODY
SIMPLY INSIST UPON BITING BY THE
NOW.
>> Laura: I DID MY BEST TO
BUCK UP FOR THE LISTENERS IT
WASN'T EASY.
IT'S TRUE HE'S WINNING PRAISE
HE'S WINNING IT FROM SOME OF THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE ENEMIES OF
HIS POPULIST AGENDA.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO REVILE HIS
OUR FRIENDS IN BOTH PARTIES IN
TO EACH OTHER.
>> THIS IS THE PRESIDENT SEE
THAT MANY PEOPLE THOUGHT
DONALD TRUMP WAS CAPABLE OF.
THE NOTION OF HIM BEING IN
COMMAND.
>> I THINK IT WAS HELPFUL BOTH
BEFORE THE CAMERAS LEFT AND
AFTER THEY LEFT.
>> Laura: THAT'S THE GUY WHO
WROTE THE BOOK TRASHING TRUMP
AND IT DIDN'T VOTE FOR HIM.
NOT SO LONG AGO THEY WERE
XENOPHOBIC, ALT RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT'S NEW FRIENDS HAVE
A FEW GOALS IN MIND.
THE REPUBLICANS WANT CHEAP LABOR
AND THE DEMOCRATS WANT NEW
VOTERS.
THERE'S ANOTHER GOAL, THEY WANT
TO SEPARATE DONALD TRUMP FROM
HIS BASE AND BREAK THE SPIRIT OF
THE POPULIST MOVEMENT.
THEY THINK THEY WILL BECAUSE
STEVE BANNON HAS BEEN SIDELINED
AND THEY THINK THEIR MOMENT HAS
ARRIVED.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO OR MAY NOT
LOYAL TO HIS SUPPORTERS AND HIS
AGENDA, THE ONE HE RAN ON, THE
ONE THAT WON ALL THAT RAVE
REVIEWS AND ALL THOSE RALLIES
WHERE PEOPLE STOOD IN LINE IN
HOURS IN THE COLD.
BAD DEAL WITH THE SOVIETS AT
REYKJAVIK.
WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT
GOVERNANCE IS DIFFICULT AND
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO GET THE
BEST DEAL YOU CAN WITH THE VOTES
YOU WERE GIVEN.
BUT I THINK KEVIN McCARTHY WHO
IS NOT EXACTLY AN IMMIGRATION
HARD-LINER HAD IT RIGHT WHEN HE
CAUTIONED THE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY DURING THAT MEETING,
HE SAID YOU CAN'T AGREE TO A
DEAL THAT COMPOUNDS THE PROBLEM.
A DEAL THAT ENDS UP ATTRACTING
MORE ILLEGALS DOWN THE ROAD.
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING
SOMETHING ELSE.
THAT HE'S PLAYING A SMOOTH GAME
WITH REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
AND THE MEDIA.
WHILE HE CONVEYS AN OPENNESS TO
NEGOTIATING, I LOVE YOU GUYS,
HE'S FORCEFULLY STAKING OUT HIS
NOT JUST THAT.
JUST THIS WEEK, THERE ARE REALLY
ENCOURAGING SIGNS.
THE PRESIDENT IS DOING THE HARD
WORK OF ENFORCEMENT.
BE HERE TEMPORARILY ARE GOING TO
FINALLY HAVE TO GO HOME BECAUSE
THE HURRICANE IS OVER.
TODAY, THE ADMINISTRATION RATED
ABOUT 100 AND 7-ELEVEN'S HUNTING
FOR ILLEGAL EMPLOYEES AND GOING
AFTER THE EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
ABUSING THEM AND ABUSING THE
SYSTEM.
THIS IS THE KIND OF ROBUST,
PROACTIVE ENFORCEMENT THAT
AMERICANS EXPECT AND SUPPORTERS
DEMAND.
WHEN IT COMES TO ANY DACA DEAL,
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO REALIZE
THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT MATTER
ABOVE ALL ELSE.
NUMBER ONE, DACA IS THE ONLY
LEVERAGE HE HAS TO IMPLEMENT HIS
ENTIRE AGENDA.
NUMBER TWO, DEMOCRATS FAVOR
GRANTING CITIZENSHIP TO THESE
ILLEGAL ALIENS BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE IT IS THE ABSOLUTE KEY
TO ACHIEVING A SUPER MAJORITY,
THEY WANT THAT IN EVERY KEY
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE AT STAKE
THAN THE FUTURE OF THE DREAMERS.
THIS COULD DECIDE THE FATE OF
THE COUNTRY.
I'M GOING TO WAIT TO SEE WHAT
THE FINAL DACA PROPOSAL LOOKS
LIKE BUT IF IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
A WALL, A REAL WALL, NOT A SEE
THROUGH WALL, EXPECT A POLITICAL
REVOLT FROM THE BASE -- WHICH
MEANS LOSING THE HOUSE AND MAYBE
EVEN LOSING THE SENATE.
CHAIN MIGRATION ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY.
BADLY THEY DON'T EXIST AT ALL,
TO DEFEND THE PRESIDENT?
DICK DURBIN, LINDSEY GRAHAM, OR
ALL THOSE HARD RIGHT PEOPLE
WHOSE RADIO SHOWS ARE ON
FOX NEWS?
THE PRESIDENT DID NOT PROMISE
HIS SUPPORTERS, HE    , AND OPAU
HIS SUPPORTERS, HE    , AND OPAE
ELECTRONIC FENCE, HE PROMISED
THEM A BIG BEAUTIFUL WALL.
UNLESS A CHAIN MIGRATION IS
ENDED, I FEAR YOUR MOST ARDENT